Why the Ottoman Empire collapsed? Simple enough for a kid to understand.
For 600 years, the Ottoman Empire was one of the most powerful forces on Earth.
It controlled three continents, sat at the center of world trade.
Then it was gone. It didn't fall to a stronger empire. It collapsed under its own weight.
The Empire ran on conquest. New territory meant new taxes, new resources, new wealth.
But by the 1700s, there was nowhere left to expand easily.
The money stopped flowing in. Meanwhile, Europe was industrializing factories,
railroads, modern weapons. The Ottomans were still running a medieval economy.
They borrowed money from European banks to modernize, then couldn't pay it back.
European powers used the debt to extract concessions, trading rights, territory, influence.
Slowly, the Empire that once terrified Europe became dependent on it.
World War I finished it. The Ottomans backed the losing side.
When Germany fell, the Empire was carved up by Britain and France in a single conference.
Borders were drawn by European diplomats who had never visited the region.
Those borders still cause conflict today. Six centuries of power ended in an afternoon
meeting in Paris. And that's just one story inside Paladin. It's like Duolingo but for
history lovers. Addictive, smart, surprisingly fun. Try it now and become the most intelligent
person in the room.